wir unterbrechen das programm für eine
wichtige mitteilung was war denn deinen
kommentaren los der link zum video ist
hier unter me ich habe den eindruck hier
gibt es mehrere erhebliche
missverständnisse und bei einigen ein
heftiges defizite in sachen demokratie
verständnis im video zum laser
scheibenwischer von tesla habe ich
dieses t-shirt getragen nazis raus aus
den stadien und das hat für einige ich
sage mal verwirrte kommentare gesorgt
und werbung ist hier oben eingeblendet
weil ich einen kauf link zum t-shirt
verlinkt habe davon bekomme ich
allerdings keinen cent klicks und
science fiction los geht's das ist mir
jetzt auch egal wenn das video nicht
monetarisiert wird weil es um
rechtsradikalismus geht also erstmal zu
diesem t-shirt hier und warum ich es
habe beim sv babelsberg 03
ja bis 2017 einen unangenehmen
zwischenfall im spiel gegen energie
cottbus wurden von beiden seiten pyros
gezündet und von energie cottbus fans
wurde skandiert arbeit macht frei
babelsberg 03 und zecken [ __ ] und
juden babelsberg 03 gut solchen nazis
gehören offensichtlich nicht zu den
dichtern und denkern reimen passiert nun
zufällig selbst wenn es gewollt ist ein
babelsberg verwundert nazischweine raus
beide vereine wurden verurteilt aber nur
im urteil gegen babelsberg 03 wird der
spruch nazischweine raus vom
nordostdeutschen fußballverband erwähnt
die nazi sprüche also die die nazis
skandiert haben die fallen unter den
tisch babelsberg 03 wehrt sich
juristisch das ist eine längere
geschichte aber das kostet eine menge
geld und zur unterstützung verkauft der
verein eben dieses t shirt deshalb habe
ich einst gekauft und trage ist der link
zum shirt ist hier unterm ihn deshalb
ist das video auch übrigens als werbung
gekennzeichnet ich bekomme allerdings
kein geld dafür
das geht alles an babelsberg 03 kommen
wir jetzt zum ersten erheblichen
missverständnis politischen botschaften
hätten auf einem wissenschafts kanal
nichts zu suchen okay politische
botschaft ernsthaft das würde ja
bedeuten dass nazis irgend etwas mit
politik zu tun haben würden
politik ist ja laut definition die
gesamtheit aller interaktionen die auf
die autor aktive
verteilung von werten materiellen wie
geld oder nicht materiellen wie
demokratie abziehen nun da gibt es schon
mal einen klitzekleinen haken wer sich
heute in der tradition der
nationalsozialisten des 12 jahre
dauernden tausendjährigen reiches als
nazi definierten da gibt es tatsächlich
den ein oder anderen leider ohne sich
auch nur in deren traditionen sieht kann
schon mal kein demokrat sein denn wenn
es um demokratie geht da ist von werten
die rede rassismus fremdenfeindlichkeit
antisemitismus und so weiter sind ja
keine werte sondern genau das gegenteil
sprich jegliches eintreten gegen nazis
ist unpolitisch es hat nur mit einem zu
tun mit anstand deshalb ist es auch
gesellschaftlicher konsens unter
demokraten jedweder couleur gegen nazis
einzutreten und damit einfach eine
selbstverständlichkeit jeder anständige
mensch hat ein solches t shirt zu
begrüßen basta
und noch eine zweite absolute
fehlinformation nur am rande ich habe
überhaupt nichts gemein mit
linksextremisten und auch die sind
undemokratisch und zu verurteilen aber
was hier fälschlicherweise kolportiert
wird und ich hiermit direkt mal richtig
stelle trotz g20 begehen
rechtsextremisten deutlich deutlich mehr
straftaten als linksextremisten und beim
morgen sind linksextremisten
ich habe ein müder abklatsch der
rechtsradikalen rechtsextremer terrorist
mord und totschlag mit mutmasslichen
hunderten fällen auf linksextremen
terrors trifft das nicht zu
selbst wenn man die raf in den
siebzigern noch dazu zählt und drittes
missverständnis gerade auf einem
wissenschafts kanal ist es geboten im
geboten ein solches t shirts zu tragen
der nazis vertreten diese ideologie denn
mehr ist es nicht gegen alle
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse nazis
sind wissenschafts feindlich und
deswegen ist es auf einem wissenschafts
kanal wie clixoom wichtig sich deutlich
gegen nazis zu stellen spricht jeder der
mit diesem t-shirt irgendein problem hat
kann und soll diesen kanal d abonnieren
solcher menschenfeindliche abschaum hat
er einfach nichts zu suchen haut ab haut
einfach ab
ihr seid nur geht das dass er überhaupt
thematisiert und diskutiert werden muss
das ist wirklich eine schande hat er
keine schule erziehung also hier heißt
es auf klicks ab sofort nazis raus aus
diesem kanal und an alle anderen bis
dann bleib dran